[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ça va vous allez bien ouais
super je suis très content de faire la
conclusion de ce telex parié dans cette
si belle salle quel grand rex
je suis content d'être là même si c'est
pas facile de prendre la parole après
après toutes ces belles prises de
paroles surtout quand les humoristes
quand j'ai entendu la prise de parole de
rania thaler qui nous a parlé de son
voyage de syrie jusqu'en europe
j'ai mis de côté mais vannes sur les
transports en commun
ok mais je suis content de faire cette
conclusion chez tedx paris m'ont dit ça
serait bien qu'ils fassent une
conclusion le thème c'est le slow slow
c'est le fait de prendre son temps de
renouer avec la vie par contre tu es
gentil à 8 minutes chez félix paris en
fait on se dit les idées pour changer le
monde mais quand même on n'a pas que ça
à
on rigole bien j'ai bien aimé
l'introduction de michel tout à l'heure
qui nous a parlé de l'accélération de
nos vies avec l'arrivée de l'iphone qui
a accéléré nos vies j'ai bien aimé moi
je me sens pas vraiment concerné parce
que je suis sur android mais mais c'est
vrai que le slow c'est intéressant moi
j'ai remarqué que le temps est relatif
quand même autre monde
selon l'endroit où tu es dans le monde
le temps n'est pas pareil un jour je
voyage et en afrique je voulais aller à
la plage en voiture j'ai demandé un mec
sait à combien de temps la plage mais ni
si tu peux rouler même quinze minutes
c'est trop j'avais l'impression d'être
dans matrix mais le slow slow c'est
quand même un bon concept le fait de
renouer avec le temps de ralentir un peu
nos vies ils ont inventé le concept de
slow food par opposition à la fast food
on est d'accord ces gens qui ont trouvé
ce concept n'ont jamais vécu un repas de
famille française le dimanche 1 1
ce genre de repas qui termine à 17
heures mais le lendemain
ouais tu sors de ta vie tu te remets en
question tu as l'impression d'avoir mûri
et plus lucide été plus lucide après le
4e gecip de tonton déjà tu vois l'avenir
carrément temps tu es dans le canapé
comme ça qu'est ce tu fais je regarde ma
descendance vialas lotivy aussi massucci
vie puisque apparemment la télé va trop
vite on a envie ils ont diffusé la
transhumance des rênes pendant une
semaine ça va loin quand même un peu non
remarqué en france n'a pas besoin de ça
pour laszlo tivi on à christine angot
ceci une interview de christine angot ça
peut paraître de repas de famille non
mais c'est vrai que ça avec le slot
c'est bien c'est bien de ralentir après
s'il vient ralentir quand le moment est
bon parce que quand même on est
difficile tant envie que ça fasse plus
vite même ouais tout à l'heure agnès
nous a parlé des slows dans les boums
c'était bien le clou quand tu étais
amoureux mais quand tu danses avec la
mauvaise personne
c'est long
théâtre et a pas de conversation
t'attends tu es obligé d'écouter lara
fabian
il était potes qui souffre de ta gueule
faut pas insister dans ces cas-là trouve
trouver un échappatoire
je suis désolé j'ai devoir y aller je
crois que j'ai oublié de mettre mon nom
sur mon gobelet dire qu'il ya des gens
qui ont danser des slows avec christine
angot ils sont même pas invitée à tmx
il ya un autre moment qui sera toujours
long sur lequel l'iphone n'aura aucune
prise c'est ce moment au stade
desjardins a déjà dit au revoir et
appelle l'ascenseur 1
c'est ce moment tu sors de ce que ton
pote j'étais super ton dîner à super la
prochaine fois c'est chez moi
allez salut
ok et rentrent pas chez lui ce qu'on
voit là c'est ce qu'on appelle un slot
malaise non c'était une belle soirée
comme c'est une belle soirée j'écoutais
un peu les prises de parole et cette
prise de parole aussi sur le sommeil qui
était intéressante su pour moi je suis
pour qu'on dorme plus aussi souvent
cerexhe ce qui dans peut se la pète un
peu on a tous un paquet qui nous dit
souvent elle chante jet lag ce que je
reviens d'afrique du sud c'était génial
même il ya qu une heure de décalage en
fait ouais mais tu comprends en afrique
le temps est pas pareil c'est une
grandeur tout est grand là bas comme
leur coeur d'ailleurs comme une mine de
cobalt aussi qui nous permettent de
créer des grands iphone tout est grand
en afrique sauf les enfants qui sont
exploités dans les mines et où
l'ambiance
qu'est-ce qu'on engueule dont on a parlé
beaucoup d'innovations aussi des futurs
cette hausse en pense et les gens qui
travaillent dans les start up dans la
salle par applaudissements
j'ai dit par applaudissements le mec il
a levé la main
c'est ça le futur
on est bien
non mais en général ils le disent pas
trop souvent et il travaille pas être
vraiment dans une start up dans la start
up c'est une manière sympa de dire
qu'ils étaient au chômage
mais c'est la mode c'est un mode macro
adore les startups macron il adore les
start up créée dans le documentaire sur
mac prompt à un moment et dimanche avec
mon équipe de campagne on travaille un
peu comme une start up c'est à dire quoi
travailler comme une start up c'est à
dire que tu payes pas les gens ouais
ouais c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas payé
mais on travaille en basket on voit des
smoothies aux épinards c'est sympa moi
j'en peux plus de certains plans il me
fatigue etc la star il ya trop il ya
trop trop le pire c'est celui qui me dit
moi j'ai investi dans une start-up
arrête ta prêter 100 euros at-on
colloque lui il a une idée en fumant
apps est ok et il pense ce
révolutionnaire parce que son conseiller
pôle emploi l'encouragent forcément ça
leur fait un chômeur de moins
officiellement
mais bien sûr pierrick une appli qui
géolocalise les prostituées dans ce toi
mon pote tu es le prochain marché car b
acc à 100 j'en veux plus des start up et
leurs innovations bizarre une appli qui
te permet de vendre terrestre vente
terrestre ça c'est novateur st ça
s'appelle la crevard 10
dream est et reste pokémon go auparavant
c'était révolutionnaire si pokémon go ça
existe depuis longtemps en birmanie et
ça ça n'a pas l'air au in glasgow
attrapez les tous qu'est-ce qu'on est
une machine à une machine à jus qui
s'est vendu à la silicon valley c'était
hyper novateur ils ont levé des millions
de dollars pour sa utiliser ces
nouvelles nespresso du jus il ya quatre
tonnes de pression dessus 4 tonne de
pression pour faire du jus pas vraiment
besoin de cape town pour faire du jus
une tonne aurait suffi une main pour
faire des justes était au courant de ça
ou pas vraiment disant qu'ils y seront
cape town de pression je pouvais me
faire des jus d'orange france parpaings
[Applaudissements]
fatigue etc la start-up ya les livres
sur la start up à la fnac le rayon a
considérablement augmenté parce que tout
le monde en rêve
tu vois pas tous les livres talent et
les conseils de xavier niel comment
monter sa start up comme en ibérie zay
sa mère
non mais c'est quand même sympa moi je
vais en prison quand même que les
start-ups et les gens qui cherchent des
solutions pour des problèmes qu'on n'a
pas encore voilà c'est la conclusion que
que je vais faire de cette soirée
je pense je pense quand même vous avez
l'air content vous a l'air d'avoir passé
une bonne soirée je suis sûr que
beaucoup d'entre vous sont en train de
se dire c'était une bonne soirée mais je
me demande quand même si à des restos
encore au vert je vous vois je vous vois
il y en a qui se prépare à partir et sa
conclusion pas faire la queue au parking
c'est normal ce serait dommage quand
même de terminer au mcdo du coin
après une soirée ted alors mais c'est
sûr mais en même temps c'est sûr que
c'est le mcdo qui ferme le plus tard un
vrai que c'est sympa de vouloir changer
le monde
problème c'est que l'avantagé d'un monde
de merde c'est qu'il reste des trucs
pratiques
allez bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]